these leaders represent 300 million
people on the Horn of Africa they
believe they have the necessary leverage
to stop the fighting in Sudan
Malik agar is Sudan's representative
here he's the deputy chairman of that
country's transitional sovereignty
Council this is a regional organization
and most of them are the neighbors also
Sudan they are directly concerned and
they are directly affected by the war
and they knows the the two fighting
forces and they have relations with all
these one of another of the two forces
so that's the leverage they have
[Music]
war between Sudan's Army and the
paramilitary rapid support force is the
rsf broke out in April over tensions
linked to a plan for a transition to
civilian rule agar is a veteran
politician and fighter leading the Sudan
people's Liberation movement like the
dozens of other armed groups in Sudan
the splm has remained neutral in this
battle
and when you start the war like this in
Sudan of course there is so many uh
playing elements stakeholders in the
Sudan then you have other armed groups
which are not part of this fighting they
have taken consciously to be a neutral
to the fighting and then any Innova has
external elements we don't know how this
is still external elements are going to
play out in the in the Sudan the other
countries here are worried the conflict
could spread people will will flee the
country going all around the neighbor
countries they may feel outside the
continent and that's what we are
avoiding so that are the consequences
farming diseases insecurity in the
sub-region so I got the
intergovernmental Authority on
development says in 10 days their
delegates will have met both sides in
Sudan with a goal of bringing
hostilities to an end
has also given itself two weeks to
persuade both sides in Sudan to allow a
humanitarian Corridor to be set up and
there are also plans to organize a
national dialogue for the people of
Sudan but these are ambitious aims given
the enormous challenges they've been
even getting both parties to agree to
the shortest of ceasefires
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Djibouti